As Patricinhas de um lado empregadinha
do outro a como me custou entender que
eu deveria mesmo era me lixar para o
preconceito dos outros
só a ponta do iceberg que você vê no
corresponde a oceano que o meu gelo pode
preencher a superfície que você consegue
enxergar não compreende os limites que
eu vim para superar
bom e que dificuldade da eles têm
aceitarem que moradia no condomínio não
era fruto do trabalho de limpeza dos
patrões não mas fruto da Conquista de
Quem veio antes de mim e que ainda
supera muitos foliões
e a preta no meio da brincadeira como
compreender que eu era privilegiada isso
era sempre a preferida na hora das
pedradas no Campo Florido que para mim
era minado na zona de conforto que para
mim era de confronto reais de mim se eu
não quisesse de forte essa cara e nem
engolir o choro
e aflita desenho lado encaixar viver num
Limbo que na cabeça me permitiu receber
no coração apertar mas na alma nunca me
curar já que para Os Pretos eu vivia no
luxo e não podia reclamar mas Bendita a
Hora Em Que meus ancestrais eu decidi
escutar e eles prontamente vieram me
orientar os nossos fios um a um por lá
ir com a inspiração de ar ele EA
proteção de ogunhê eu era excluída por
nunca ter ido a Disney quando entendi
que maturidade de racismo não condizem
com que vim para viver que a cor da pele
era Justamente a armadura que ia me
fazer doer e com as dores amadurecer
e onde Sempre querer me encaixar em
padrões estão sempre creme afundar entre
milhões mas eu e sempre de lembrar dos
Passos que caminhei dos Prazeres que
abdiquei para tomar o rumo que tomei
e o dedo aponte para si mesmo
conscientize-se da Própria Consciência
aí vai ajudar lei é sair dizendo
maledicência se você não foi forte por
sir os sacos pão de te oprimir então
Levante a cabeça e lembre de ouvir
somente as vozes que querem saber sorrir
obrigada
E aí